well brian people have questions after
the nevada department of wildlife
decision to euthanize a mountain lion in
the southwest valley
now the department is now explaining why
it came to that decision on tuesday
joe muller is live at the apartment
complex where it happened at flamingo
and hualapai joe
well here at this location we're about a
mile and a half away from the edge of
town and it was early yesterday when
that mountain line made its way
to this apartment complex you see behind
us here after reportedly trying to say
they
sedated multiple times wildlife
officials say they needed to do
something before someone here got hurt
i saw the back of it going under the car
i said damn i look big
this urban apartment complex is the last
place you would expect to see a mountain
lion
we saw a guy walking his dog and we was
like sir was like hold on
you know it's a mountain lion out here
kendrick jones says he was shocked by
the sighting
i don't know how he got in there but it
was terrifying for a minute
jones says it took two hours to get the
mountain lion out nevada department of
wildlife officials say it was euthanized
at the apartment complex
that decision sparked outrage on social
media many people questioning why the
cat wasn't sedated and relocated
we tried multiple times to sedate the
animal
and after multiple attempts were
unsuccessful we made the very difficult
decision to euthanize it for public
safety reasons
public information officer ashley
sanchez says after being in that complex
for some time they were worried about
someone getting hurt
we're in an apartment complex where
there's people around
and anything can happen mountain lion
sightings are up
another one was spotted this past april
so far there have been 31 sightings this
year compared to 15 in 2020
she says urban growth and drought
conditions are contributing factors
whether it's pools fountains golf
courses
there's abundant food and water in
neighborhoods which they're not able to
find
in the wild right now
now back out here live the department
does expect to get more reports of
sightings as this drought continues
they are asking people to not feed or
give water to wild animals such as those
mountain lions or even coyotes
now that mountain lion that was
euthanized here at this location was
sent to a lab
for testing reporting live in the
southwest valley joe muller 8 news now